cualquier economía es algo súper
complicado ahora hay que pensar por qué
por qué buenas economías tienden a
asociarse con un nivel moderado de
inflación que también a su vez esto nos
va a ayudar a informarnos para cuando
tengamos estanflación que es inflación
con una mala economía en una buena
economía el empleo está arriba entonces
los empleados tienen más poder de
negociación hay más personas que quieren
contratar hay menos que quieren su
trabajo por lo tanto el salario sube y
como tienes a más personas con empleo y
esos que tienen empleo tienen mejor
salario puedes imaginar que entonces la
demanda subirá además personas que
tienen más dinero en los bolsillos y si
la demanda sube entonces las compañías
los servicios todo será más utilizado y
si todo es más utilizado entonces las
compañías las empresas tendrán más
utilidades sobre todo esto si se acercan
a la plena utilización
si ven que la plena utilización está en
el camino van a querer invertir más y de
hecho podrían impulsar más esa plena
utilización y obtener más beneficios
subiendo los precios
aquí es donde donde la inflación
moderada aparece el hecho de que haya
más demanda el hecho de que puedas
producir más y puedas subir precios aquí
es donde el nivel moderado de inflación
aparece aquí hay un pequeño bucle de
retroalimentación negativa si los
precios suben esto va a inhibir la
demanda un poco y por eso se le llama
inflación moderada no estamos hablando
de una loca espiral inflacionaria no
pero el efecto neto de más utilización y
más inversión conducirá a un incremento
en la oferta entonces aquí una vez más
hay un tipo de concepto básico de
economía si la oferta sube los precios
si la oferta sube esto también tendría
un impacto inhibitorio en los precios
entonces dibujo para ver el bucle de
retroalimentación negativa aquí aquí hay
retroalimentación negativa
ahora para completar el bucle si
invertimos más construimos más fábricas
más compañías o más capacidad para hacer
servicios lo que sea esto hará que el
empleo incremente y si tenemos más
utilidades entonces la compañía sentirá
que quiere crecer se siente como con un
amortiguador que lo impulsa se siente
optimista por el futuro y esto ayudará
al empleo y obviamente la utilización si
hay más necesitaremos a más personas por
lo tanto también esto incrementa el
empleo esto es como un bucle de
retroalimentación y puede sesgar esto un
poco más pero esta es la idea general de
por qué una moderna moderada inflación
está asociada con este circuito vicioso
que normalmente veríamos en una buena
economía